good morning everyone welcome to this
workshop on kovat 19 and this is gonna
be a workshop on the genomics side of
the novel coronavirus this workshop is
designed for teachers students and their
parents we hope that as a result of this
workshop you also can get excited about
bioinformatics as a good way to study
biology not having access to your lab or
being able to conduct experiments
especially not with this new virus in
this workshop we will speak about the
genomic data analysis and will try to
understand how different data analysis
tools can help us detect viral genomes
in next-generation sequencing data help
distinguish between different viral
strains for example how is this novel
coronavirus different from other
coronaviruses how we can identify
specific functionally significant
changes in the viral genomes and in
general how can we discuss biology from
a data perspective so some of these
elements are listed here on the screen
what you see here is the corona virus
and the message that it carries in its
RNA we can see the code of this message
in the nucleotide sequence we can also
study relationships between different
corona viruses which is what you see
right here in the back of phylogenetic
tree that we'll talk about and then how
do we understand the biological
significance of the different variations
that we actually find and in the middle
you see some of the tools that we'll be
talking about and some of those tools
include multiple sequence alignment as
well as bylaw Janee how to study
relationships of these different viral
sequences before we start though I want
to mention that this workshop is
organized as a collaboration between
Pine biotech and science coach and so I
want to give a few minutes to Jill who
is the founder and executive director of
science coach to introduce her
organization and share with you more of
the details about the resources and
program
that are available for teacher training
and high-level student research projects
so Jill I'm going to unmute you now good
morning everyone
like Elia said my name is Jill Malcolm
I'm the executive director of the
science coach program we are a program
that allows us teacher six through
twelfth grade teachers and students to
really explore some type of science that
they are particularly interested in and
to do research that allows them to take
that research to another whole level so
we allow the students to choose a
question of personal interest increate a
procedure to test that hypothesis or to
develop that concept and then they
arrive at the answers with hold the
level of validity in and it really
builds confidence in the students to
help them learn how to solve real-world
problems we were through work with
students six to twelfth grade
in public private and home schools in
the United States at this immediate
moment so a year ago we started a pilot
with Pineville
to try to bring the whole science of
bioinformatics to high school students
we have a informatics website and that
link is in the chat and you're welcome
to use the courses that we have up there
for free the results that we had were
absolutely astounding we had students
who knew absolutely nothing about
bioinformatics two and three months
being able to run their own data through
using the pine bio system that's nothing
short of miraculous these students we
actually had one Hannah
that did a gene expression experiment in
diabetes and looking at actually
identifying not only that gene but
figuring out how to allow
pharmaceuticals in the future to be able
to suppress that gene expression which
in layman's terms could actually provide
the key to allowed gene based diseases
like diabetes to be cured
so this is real research that the
students are doing and in order to
support the students we also train the
teachers so we have a summer training
program going on this June in July we
will be doing some virtual training and
we invite anybody who's interested in
being a part of the science coach
program who would like anybody who'd
like to do a high-level research with
their students and then those projects
are entered into competitions and then
sometimes if they come up with a novel
idea or a patentable idea or an idea
that can turn into a business we
actually help them do that so the
relationship with Pyne bio has been
phenomenal and we continue to increase
the availability for this content and
making it adaptable adapted to a six to
12th grade student alright great thank
you very much Jill so if anyone wants to
learn more about science coach
bioinformatics there's a link that
points to this website this website has
some materials that you can start
looking at but I also want to mention
that science coaches beyond just
bioinformatics and you can look them up
on Google or I'm sure that Jill can post
the link to the science coach website so
okay so let's start talking about covert
19 and what we will talk about in this
session so covert 19 the name stands for
coronavirus disease and 19 of course is
the year that this epidemic started 2019
so what we'll do in this workshop is
we'll try and look at some of these
phenotypes some of these things that
characterize this virus so what is this
corona virus itself how does it cause
the disease and what is the result of
viral transmission from animal
reservoirs where potentially that
viruses came from and how does that
enter into the humans itself and we'll
talk about all of these things from a
perspective of the collected data that
has been publicly available since 2019
for this specific virus the novel
coronavirus but also for a long time for
the past decade are available for other
for corona viruses and so we have as a
result of this publicly available data
any one of us has access to very
accurate sequences of the genomes of
these viruses produced by top biologists
biologists and labs around the world
from many different locations including
China and the US Italy Israel
Africa and other places so we really
have access to a unique repository of
publicly available data and we are the
public so of course we are able to to
access this data but the question is
what do we do with this data right so
the question is how do we actually make
use of the data how do we analyze these
genomes and what is it that we can
understand from such analysis so these
types of programs are supported by a
number of different universities in the
US and around the world that Pine
biotech is helping develop materials and
tools to support their research and
support the learning activities that
they have for bioinformatics
I'm sorry somebody is here annotating my
screen so I'm going to try and pause
that beeps and Mohit maybe you guys can
take a look at how to erase those I
think it's somewhere here and that okay
here we're going to clear all drawings
all right great
thank you okay so as I was mentioning
pine biotech is developing a number of
resources that include some tools as
well as curriculum that people can that
different universities use to teach and
support research projects and these
include an online web-based platform
that could be that could be used for
different types of tools different types
of analyses for example multiple
sequence alignment and for genetic
analysis that we'll talk about today but
also we offer a variety of different
courses that span a different types of
datasets for example next-generation
sequencing data that we'll talk about
today in the context of genomics
transcriptomics metagenomic studies but
also provides tools for analysis of
other types of data including structural
data analysis and mass spec and and
others providing big data capabilities
and machine learning capabilities to
novel users users that would like to use
tools without having the technical
engineering background but also
providing high-level research tools for
big data for researchers that study a
variety of different projects so what
we'll cover in today's session are
several topics that are extracted from a
full program that we have on
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
where we take projects from published
data sets and weari analyze that data so
that we can understand how to analyze
how to interpret them analysis results
and how can we use bio informatics
to study various aspects of viral
infections of different pathogens so
this full program is going to start on
May 4th I would say that it's more at a
college level program however however
what we've seen are a lot of students as
Jill mentioned when they're introduced
to some of these ideas and these tools
they're absolutely capable of taking
advantage of these tools and making them
make turning their own projects into
something that is competitive so the
full program again will start on May 4th
make sure to check that out by that
following that link that be posted in
chat
ok so in today's session we will talk
about zone notic spillover or how
different viruses can originate in
animals and transfer to humans will talk
about the cell entry and invasion of the
immune response how do the viruses do
that we'll talk about how they produce
proteins and replicate using the host
cellular machinery we'll talk about
different analysis analysis approaches
that help us detect viral genomes and
next-generation sequencing data when you
take a sample from a bat a Pangolin or a
human how do you know that there is a
virus using next-generation sequencing
we'll talk about viral strains and
haplotypes so we often talk about FASTA
files of those assembled genomes and in
those genomes we really cannot find a
lot of the detailed variation that
typically occurs in patient samples
we'll also talk about how to find
annotate and characterize the from
mutation so what are mutations different
types of mutations and what is their
significance based on the change that
they produce we'll also talk about how
to find and use some of the data sets
that are available online so we'll
actually go to a database where we will
find some sequences from the SARS MERS
and other corona viruses that are
available and we'll talk about how to
specifically find a coded nineteen
samples and then we'll also look at
different hosts animals humans
animals okay so the coronavirus has been
in the news we all heard and read a lot
of publications and news stories we
probably saw a lot of business but we
will be talking today about the corona
virus from a genomic perspective right
so I want to kind of make sure that
everybody is focused on looking at the
corona virus not as a particle that
necessarily causes disease but first at
the basic level what is the message what
is the message that the viral particle
carries so we already started talking
about this there is a sequence and this
is a sequence of nucleotides that is
tightly packaged in something that is
probably similar to a droplet of oil in
water so imagine in a droplet of oil and
inside that droplet there is a message
and that message can be studied so the
sequence of that message can be studied
by looking at each individual nucleotide
now we can also look at how that
nucleotide sequence can be translated
into amino acid sequence and then built
into proteins of course that does not
happen by itself to build those proteins
the virus has to access the cell of the
host to utilize different elements of
that cell machinery to build that
protein but we can look at different
types of viruses for example they come
from different hosts and there that
means that their sequence should be
different if they're able to access them
the machinery from animals or from
humans they need to make adaptations so
they actually need to change that
sequence they really cannot change
anything else and that is the process of
mutations accumulation of those
mutations and the study of those
mutations really are possible by
multiple sequence alignment and as a
result we can look at how those
sequences are related to each other and
by that way we can study how exactly are
they different to each from each other
or
similar to each other and build some
kind of a sense of how are they
interrelated so let's talk about that
relationship
viruses are organized into groups by
what's called taxonomy so we talk about
a virus like a corona virus for example
that really means many different things
in fact corona viruses have different
genera and there is alpha beta gamma and
delta corona viruses and they can be
very different in fact some of them can
only infect specific non-human hosts and
some of them are specific to humans so
there are different types of viruses
they have different properties but at a
deeper level
they are also divided into subgroups and
those are called species and then within
those species there are additional
variation so in fact a lot of these
human coronaviruses including types 229
e n o 63 OC 43 and HKU one usually cause
mild to moderate upper respiratory tract
illnesses like the common cold
so most people actually get infected
with one or even more of these viruses
at some point in their lives a lot of
these viruses come from alpha and beta
generis and so when we say I got a cold
that cold could be caused by multiple
different pathogens a good chance that
if you had a cold it was caused by one
of the beta or alpha corona viruses so
what about this novel coronavirus write
this novel coronavirus
is actually a specific strain and that
strain is a human SARS CLV - corona
virus - and that belongs to the B
species of the beta corona viruses of
the corona Bias family so it is a very
specific strain and we now know from
multiple genomes that have been made
publicly available and already analyzed
that even within the strain there are
now multiple strains that could be
detected and specifically defined by
there are mutations by the changes in
their genome so the differences in
phenotype the differences in how they
cause disease are significant before
2002 it was thought that coronaviruses
cause only self-limiting and mild
infection of the respiratory tract in
human beings two of the corona viruses
considered during this time were beta
corona viruses and the other were alpha
corona viruses they are endemic so that
means that they typically spread in a
certain geographic area and cause about
fifteen to thirty percent of the
infections of the respiratory tract each
year in the areas that they are endemic
to so what that means is that typically
a virus infects people in a restricted
geographic area and that causes mild
symptoms and so most people don't get
tested right so we don't really know how
widespread really the virus is until it
starts causing severe symptoms so for
example previous outbreak of the severe
acute respiratory syndrome which is
called SARS happen in China in 2002 to
2003 and it was caused by the SARS
coronavirus which is also a beta corona
virus at the time this outbreak was
among the most severe illnesses that had
occurred due to a corona virus more than
8,000 people had that illness during the
epidemic researchers obtained viruses
that were closely related to the SARS
coronavirus is from various exotic
animals such as raccoon dogs and the
Himalayan palm civets but it's generally
accepted that the SARS coronavirus was
first found in bats right so think about
where this virus comes from think about
what it causes the symptom that it
causes how it spreads and how could that
be an insight a key for us to be able to
study these different viruses so in this
session what we want to do is really
start talking about some of these
concepts in order for all of us to start
skin questions right so the goal of this
webinar is not to give you a lecture the
goal of this webinar is for you to
formulate your question to know for
example what questions can you ask so
not all questions could be asked from
all data sets right
we also have datasets that can answer
very specific questions so when you
think of some of the some of the topics
that we discussed up until now for
example where it came from that is a
question that we can ask from a very
specific data set and we can collect
that data set right so we need to know
how to coordinate the questions that we
can ask with the data sets that will
answer that question but to answer the
question we need to have appropriate
tools so we cannot just ask a question
and it will tell us we need to analyze
the data and the data typically contains
a lot of noise noise being a lot of
information that does not answer the
question that we're asking and signal
and the signal are actually features
characteristics that do answer the
question that we have asked and then we
will ask we will try to interpret the
results right so after the analysis is
performed we will try to use additional
information that could be found
somewhere that will help us interpret
that the results that we got okay
so as I'm going through the next
question please try to formulate your
own questions and I will pause and I
will ask you and you will be able to
share with everyone in chat what is a
good question that you think that might
be asked from the data sets that we will
discuss today so question number one
what is the origin of the novel
coronavirus so this novel coronavirus
we talked about that possibly it could
come from an animal source but a
question would be which animal what
location and how did it actually get
into humans so if we know something
about bats we know for sure that they
have different proteins on the surface
of their cells that are different from
the human cells and those proteins are
essential for the virus to enter the
host
so if there was a big change how could
that change happen the question is more
specific though because if a change is
big then it's less likely for example if
a whole section of the genome has to be
completely different that is not likely
to occur how do we know that well the
changes in genome occur by different
processes and it's important to
understand these processes to be able to
analyze the data one of the processes
that is very common are mutations
mutations are single point changes
single nucleotide changes that could be
either one nucleotide replaced with
another one and sometimes added or
subtracted inserted or deleted and so
those occur fairly often and we actually
know approximately what is the rate of
mutations in positive strand RNA viruses
however bigger chunks are typically not
just gonna get replaced or changed in a
specific strain so how can it change
like that happen if it is indeed a
bigger change could it happen from
recombination recombination means that a
virus takes some portion from a
different virus that is maybe in close
proximity to where this virus is so
potentially we're talking about multiple
strains of a corona virus in a single
host and then we need to ask the
question well could that really happen
so let's take a look at this genome this
is the genome on NCBI so we can take
this we can take this genome and find it
on NCBI so let's just take this and we
will go to NCBI and take a look at this
genome I'm going to paste this link in
chat
okay
so please look at this link together
with me and let's take a look at what we
can understand about this type of data
so what is NCBI NCBI is the National
Center for Biotechnology information it
is a database hosted by the federal
government that helps annotate all of
the data that is published in different
publications so you will find here
genomes you will find here protein
sequences you will find here a lot of
different information about everything
that's going on so here you can see
right on top that a specific portion of
this database called the nucleotide
database is where we find this kovat 19
or SARS 2 coronavirus isolate and it has
an accession number which is this code
that you will find as we look at these
different genomes and then you can see
some of the data about the sequence so
for example you can see how long it is
it's 29,000 almost 30,000 nucleotides or
base pairs it's a single strand RNA and
you can see what is the date when it was
last updated which is March 18th so now
we can go here for example this is
version 3 of the same genome so we
submitted multiple times you can see the
taxonomy where it belongs to we talked
about that you can see who was published
by and the publication where you can
read more about the submission of this
genome and then you can see how it was
submitted by a specific organization and
um it actually replaced a different
previous version and so forth and so
then what's important about this is that
you will see that a genome has a
sequence and that sequence has a
structure right so the first question
I'm going to ask you what is this
sequence
so as you look at these letters let's
try to use this to evaluate how familiar
you are with genomic sequences what are
these letters can anyone tell me okay
great
protein sequence amino acids not amino
acids great alright so a lot of people
here are already familiar with how this
works so we'll talk a little bit more
about that and so what you indeed see
here is that this is translation right
so the process of translation is when we
take a sequence from DNA or typically a
nucleotide sequence could be from RNA
could then be transcribed so DNA is
typically transcribed to RNA and then
from RNA RNA it's translated to proteins
and so we see here the translated
version of a specific proteins so you
can see here CD s which is the coding
sequence for different genes and they
encode for protein so as you scroll down
you will see that there are different
proteins and down below what is this who
can tell me what this is DNA a
nucleotide it's okay great so
okay so these are sequences in
nucleotides that's what we want to get
at so let's take a look real quick right
we said that this is about 30,000
nucleotide or base pair long sequence
all right so let's take a look at how
many we can find right here 29 8 8 1
which is right here and then it goes all
the way right here right so this is not
a [ __ ] but we said that this is an RNA
virus so how could this be a DNA
sequence if we're talking about an RNA
virus
reverse transcription okay anybody else
cDNA gray did DNA
ene okay so now let's clarify that so
how did we get from an RNA virus to see
nucleotide so the only change between
RNA and DNA is uracil and so what we
typically record sequences of genomes is
in cDNA format because indeed the
process of sequencing uses conversion to
DNA to actually do to record those
sequences so that's why we see it like
this and the process of going from this
sequence to protein is something that we
will talk about as well okay so great so
we saw the genome so let's talk a little
bit about how we got here right how did
we get this kind of a data set okay the
approach that we will take to answer the
first question so let me remind you what
is the question the question is what is
the origin of this novel coronavirus so
if you look at this submission this was
the first genome submitted by a group
out of China of a novel SARS -
coronavirus and they submitted this
whole sequence right and the question
was where did this sequence come from so
this sequence could have come and here
you see a couple of links we will share
this publication with you after the
webinar you can see that the question
relates to how did it get there what is
the process of this sequence appeared
appearing in humans right so all of a
sudden I found this and appeared in
humans and then the question is okay how
did it get there
so potential hypothesis right somebody
formulate a hypothesis instead okay so
maybe there was a primary host
originated in something like a bat that
maybe was eaten maybe there was an
intermediate house and eventually it got
into humans right so here's a lot of
questions that we can ask where it would
come from how did it get there
what was the process of getting there
right so the only they
that we have to answer this question is
really this sequence we don't have a
private investigator in China they can
track the events back and really tell us
how did it happen all we have to answer
this question is the sequence but we're
not gonna do this on our own because
we're not biologists maybe some of them
you are I'm not a biologist so we will
follow an expert somebody that has done
it for us and just to make sure that
we're doing the right steps after we do
the right steps we'll be able to think
about it ourselves and ask additional
questions so here's a publication that
was recently published in Nature
Medicine where they took several
different sequences so those sequences
included humans are COV to the sequence
that we just looked at included a couple
of sequences from bats so you can see
bad three of them right here another
human SARS so not the novel SARS but the
older one from 2003 to 2007 and a
sequence from penguin and then by
comparing these different sequences they
found specific changes so what are the
changes that we will see here those are
two different types of changes some of
the changes are single nucleotide or a
single amino acid actually and some of
those changes are actually whole
sections that weren't inserted right so
that points to some biological
mechanisms that can explain how this
virus got from original host which we're
hypothesizing could be either bat or
penguin into the human host so we're
gonna follow this example and ask some
of the similar questions okay so but for
us to really understand how to answer
some of these questions we need to lay
down on some terminology and some of
those that terminology has to do with
how the virus enters a cell replicates
inside the cell what is the mechanism of
how that works the which is on the
biology side and some of it has to do
with informatics or data science so for
example we need to understand file
formats what is a faster what is a fast
queue file was a PDB file
what are nucleotides what are amino
acids and how can they be described when
we talk about insertions deletions
substitutions etc so let's talk about
some of these things just to make sure
that everybody's on the same page all
right who can tell me what this is
you can write your answers in chat
sequence alignment and GS great hit nap
multiple alignment sequencing okay
alright so some good answers right here
right so what are we seeing we are
seeing here the output from
next-generation sequencing and it is
indeed alignment but it's not multiple
sequence alignment this is alignment of
reads reference genome so these small
pieces that you see here are reads those
reads are short portions anywhere
between 30 to 300 nucleotides long and
those have to be assembled into a genome
so one easy way to assemble a genome is
to map it on a genome that we know is
closely related so when we look at this
we see here a lot of short short
sequences those sequences are aligned to
some kind of a reference genome and then
we have a consensus which is the
agreement what all the reads mostly
agree on in terms of a sequence and we
get a new novel bit of coronavirus
genome
so that's how we got from detecting some
unknown reads from a host let's say a
bad sequencing it and then mapping it
onto a database of potential viruses and
then understanding that perhaps there is
a novel virus that is present here so
that is one aspect that we will talk
about in the future but right now based
on this process of next generation
sequencing first then finding a
consensus of what all the reads they
agreed to that a novel sequence is we
can then characterize a novel genome and
the novel genome
the novel genome looks something like
that so again we have about 30,000 base
pair long sequence that base pair that
30,000 base pair long sequence is
organized in a number of element and
these are structures so these are genes
some of them code for proteins that are
that are going to be important for the
process of this virus replicating itself
and entering into the cell so here you
can see what the sequences look like
right so you can see that these are
actually faster files right the previous
reads that we saw were called fast queue
files typically as an output from a
next-generation sequencer but then what
we are looking at is the FASTA files and
the FASTA files really just contain the
nucleotide sequence so what are we
expecting to find in this sequence some
of the things that we are expecting to
find as a change from that reference
genome are point mutation so point
mutations could be of several different
kinds they could be substitutions where
one letter is substituted by another we
can find an insertion where one letter
is added inside a sequence and then we
can see deletion now these different
changes in that nucleotide sequence
result in different products and those
products over here are the different
amino acids that are coded by codons so
the process works like this typically
there's a gene in a DNA in our case it's
an RNA virus but typically in the DNA
let's say in a human DNA we have a gene
now gene sequence is transcribed to mRNA
which is messenger RNA which is then
translated into protein and we kind of
figured out the way this happens it
happens by taking these three nucleotide
sequences which are called codons and we
know which variations of those codons
correspond to which amino acids which
actually form the protein so you can see
here a chart of how different positions
that are changed have different effect
on the product on the protein that we
have now what are these amino acids
amino acids are actually of different
types
they have different chemical properties
so for example they could be hydrophobic
or hydrophilic they can be charged or
uncharged they have some of them have no
polar charge so these are different
these different types of amino acids are
actually important for the structure of
the protein let's think about it for a
second here is the H here's the spike
like a protein from this novel
coronavirus it has a certain structure
the structure is actually a structure of
amino acids so if we have polar charged
amino acids these amino acids have to
support the function of this protein
they're there for a reason so if they
have to be there for a reason what could
be an important property chemical
property that these proteins might have
well polar charged amino acids are
hydrophilic and they have a charge and
they typically function and binding and
catalysis so that means that they do
something why could this protein have to
have a specific charge the reason is
because it actually connects so you can
see that this protein connects to a
receptor and that connection has to
happen by using the properties of those
amino acids on the flip side some of the
aren't charged amino acids might be
facing towards the inside of the protein
so we will see how these different amino
acids actually work to support the
function of the protein that we are
studying for example the protein that we
started talking about this spike
glycoprotein what it does is it actually
helps in the entry
of the protein of the whole virus into
the human cell and so we have different
portions of each protein so remember we
talked about the sequence at the
nucleotide level that had different
sequences of genes those genes in fact
have portions and those portions are
used together to form what's called cell
fusion so the two membranes of the virus
and of the cell fused together and what
is the point of that for the virus of
course it's the entry of the RNA inside
the human cell and the entry of that RNA
is what causes disease because that RNA
starts entering a process of the cell
designed for its own mRNA and starts the
process of replication so it produces a
lot of itself we'll talk about that in a
little bit but there are also other
amino acids nonpolar amino acids which
are actually used as building blocks so
think of bricks you can have functional
things in your house you can have a door
you can have a window you can have the
doorbell you can have your fireplace and
those are functional things but you also
have to have walls and those walls
support everything they make everything
kind of stand together and so those are
gonna be a lot of those are going to be
nonpolar meal clasps now how do we go
from the sequence that we detect by
sequencing right we talk about
sequencing short reads and annotating
them together by putting them alongside
some known sequence but how do we know
what are these different sequences and
what do they actually do well a lot of
it has to do with protein function
protein function can have multiple
different aspects that we can Stipe one
is it has an amino acid sequence the
amino acid sequence can reveal sequence
similarity for example it could have a
very closely associated known sequence
that we already know what it does it can
have genomic context for example what
typical portions it has is that in the
beginning is that at the end does it
have this feature of that feature
it has feature-based so we can have for
example where typically it's found and
subcellular location or a functional
class so these are some of the tools
that we have to analyze amino acid
sequences based on just the sequence of
amino acids then we can look at the 3d
structure and the 3d structure as you
can see is how these amino acids if they
are left in their natural environment
typically fold because they are charged
because they have certain chemical
characteristics they're going to form a
certain structure and so we can look at
again different motifs and different
characteristics of those amino acids to
understand how they might fold and that
might give us insight into their
function another way to study this is to
look at high-throughput data so to
conduct experiments by changing
different things and we can start
detecting how different proteins
interact between each other for example
which protein typically binds to each
protein or we can look at gene
expression so an easy way to do this is
to sequence everything that we observe
in a Cell that for example has been
infected and then start looking at what
does it do
what are some of the functional things
that start happening to the cell once we
start that process so to do this we
actually have prepared multiple projects
that have publicly available data so
that you can study any of these
processes so for example one of the
projects that we'll look at in future
webinars like this is the the
identification of viral genomes and
patient samples using next-generation
sequencing and comparative phylogenetic
analysis so we look at how can we take a
sample from a bat or from a human and
map all of the reads on for example the
human genome or the bad genome to get a
remainder of non mapped reads that then
could identify specific viral strains by
mapping those onto a database and then
once we have those we can do comparative
analysis that will help us under
then what they might be closer or
farther away from another project that
we'll talk about is the spike
glycoprotein we'll start talking a
little bit about it today but we'll
continue talking about it in greater
detail because it is the key to host
cell binding cell entry and evasion from
immune response and we'll talk about how
some of those are also the result of a
very smart strategy by the virus in this
case to avoid detection by the immune
system and use different components of
the protein you can see that it has many
components to adapt to the different
challenges that it faces to become more
efficient and what it does and
ultimately to replicate in a way that it
is undetected until it's already
replicating a lot and finally we'll talk
about a project where they took a
specific cell type the epithelial cells
that could help understand what kinds of
proteins are being produced inside the
cell as a response to different
challenges by these types of viruses so
what they did is they took one of the
cell one of the genomes and modified one
of the genes in our genome changed
something in the viral genome infected
their potential cells and started
comparing well what happens between the
mutant and the wild-type
and how can we understand that change
and so what you can see here and we'll
talk a lot about this in the future
sessions is a principal component
analysis that helps us characterize that
there is a difference and there is a
difference here between the mutant and
the wild-type and at different time
points that's another thing that we had
or so a lot of great data is available
online and we can use very effective
tools to study this type of process at a
very detailed molecular level which is I
think very exciting okay
so before we go in so we start finding
the genomes of other coronaviruses I
want to pause here and ask if anyone has
any questions about what we covered up
until now
you
you
you
I'm not great so there's no questions
let's keep on going forward with finding
that data and seeing what we can do with
the data and I just learn about it
okay so let's remember for some of these
key things that we have multiple strains
of the same beta coronavirus they will
be called beta coronavirus one they
could be called MERS SARS or the novel
coronavirus let's remember that the
corona virus genome is going to be
approximately 30,000 nucleotides long
and it will have specific regions that
are going to be important to understand
how this virus works so when we talk
about comparing those sequences we can
compare whole genomes between each other
but that's a lot of data to compare
right that's 30,000 three diets or we
can start looking at very specific
positions that we think might be more
relevant to how it is different okay so
let's first talk about multiple sequence
alignment what is that here's a multiple
sequence alignment please take a look at
this and tell me what do you think we
are aligning and what are the
differences that could be seen please
answer your please put your answers in
the chat
okay great but DNA sequences yes so this
is not amino acids anymore right this is
right now exactly different human
versions of of which coronaviruses what
would we see here
yes different hue
infections DNA sequences okay
so let's break this down we have here
right so we have a bunch of different
viral sequences we can see that all of
them contain this severe acute
respiratory syndrome related coronavirus
right and then we have where they came
from their location USA China Spain
Israel USA etc and we have the date
right so we have the 2022 2019
2004 okay so different dates and we have
one that is used as a reference so now
let's take a look at this side of the
picture so what did we see here here we
see on top is the quality alright so
this could be called the quality of the
sequence of the consensus sequence this
is the consensus sequence or we can also
call it the frequency of mutations I
will talk about some of these things now
so we have a letter for example in all
of them at C all of a sudden in a bunch
of them it is T why do you think that
there is this change from C to T from C
to a why do we see these white boxes for
example in 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 in mean 7 what
what do you see is different in these
seven from the rest of them
mutations but why why do you think that
it what is different between these and
and these in the middle change of
country well there's USA right here
there's USA what else is different age
we don't know the age snip okay what do
we see here what is this yeah all right
great so we have different here so what
do we know about the years the novel
coronavirus started in 2019 remember
it's coded nineteen right so in 2019 so
2019 to twenty are the novel coronavirus
and and these are the old SARS
coronavirus --is that are not the novel
coronavirus okay so we're starting to
see that there are changes consistent
changes right consistent changes between
the older coronavirus and the novel
coronavirus or that the SARS coronavirus
okay so that's what multiple sequence
alignment actually tells us but as you
can see this is a very small portion of
the full genome so some other ways that
we can look at these differences we can
look at mutation frequency right
mutation frequency tells us how many how
many samples contain a change based on
you know the reference genome so for
example here you can see that there are
some changes this was the segment that
we were looking at in detail sometimes
the detail is not interesting we just
want to quantify it and so we can see
that eight out of all the sequences
contain this change and that might give
us an insight we can also look at okay
well if there's a change in the
nucleotide it doesn't actually cause the
change in that amino acid right is this
a mutation that causes change in the
protein that is being produced if it
does maybe that's more significant than
the change that we observe at the
nucleotide level right so that's where
we have the amino acid the mutation
frequency and it looks something like
this if you
zoom in but you can also map those
mutations those differences on a 3d
structure so here you can see that spike
glycoprotein from the top and you can
see the section that is enriched with
mutations so mutation frequency you can
see it as enriched with mutations okay
what kind of graph or map is this called
so again this is multiple sequence
alignment this is the quality of
consensus sequence this is based on
clustal multiple sequence alignment and
here you have mutation frequency at the
nucleotide level
this is mutation frequency at the amino
acid level and this is the transposing
of that on to a 3d structure from the
PDB file 6v exits and that also shows
your mutation frequency okay we'll talk
about all of these things in greater
detail Setia
okay here's another concept a
phylogenetic tree right so we can detect
these different mutations we can point
them we can annotate them characterize
them but first before we go into such
detail we want to understand well how
does it in general describe the data
that we have so here we have a
phylogenetic tree and what is a
phylogenetic tree tell us the final
genetic tree tall's it does us how we
think the present-day species that we
observe right so for example there when
we were looking at the we were looking
at two types right the SARS from the
previous years and SARS from 2015 2020
so that's the car the present-day
species that we observed but our
question is where could they have come
from right so they have branches that
come from a source and we think that we
think that that was the origin right so
if we want to measure distance from
origin and we think that they might have
come from a common ancestor we link them
together so that's what a phylogenetic
tree tells us and it helps us organize
their information in a certain taxonomy
these same phylogenetic trees could be
rectangular circular radio so they can
have multiple versions but they all
speak about the same thing they talk
about the relationship and they might
include some kind of a distance right so
let's take a look at an analysis of a
bunch of these different coronaviruses
from that relationship perspective so
here we see the human coronavirus HKU
one which is a beta coronavirus you can
see that it was discovered in 2005 and
to patients in Hong Kong so there right
here we have the beta coronavirus one
which is which again is very closely
related right you can see that
accountant comes from a common source
then we have MERS MERS is hypothesized
to have come from camels maybe also bats
but you can see that it was first
reported in Saudi Arabia in 2012 and it
had severe respiratory illness and a lot
of deaths so actually a high probability
of dying from that disease and it's it's
own clade right here you can see its own
Quaid then we have the SARS coronavirus
which was first reported in Asia again
in China in 2003 it was all it was
contained and no novel infections were
detected after 2004 but you can see it
also forms its own little branch right
here and we have the novel coronavirus
which is very closely related to SARS
right so right here close in the same
claim we can link this information like
we were looking at to where this came
from so a very nice website that we can
all learn from is called next string so
let's quickly just take a look at that
at that link so that we can so that we
can understand how these things are
related so you can go to neck strain and
it has several different viruses that
you can look at but let's take a look at
it now and here as I'm sorry that was to
everyone okay so please take a look at
that link here you can see how starting
from 2019 this virus has evolved right
so accumulation of mutations in these
genomes their evolution and you can play
here how it occurred and Link the data
at the genomic level right to the spread
that happened over time so here you can
see that it starts spreading from China
more samples were collected in China
eventually samples were collected in
Australia in Japan then it went to
America and to Europe so you can see
that the spread happen and we have all
of these different sequences from these
different parts right and now that you
understand multiple sequence alignment
you start understanding this chart right
here below so you can start seeing
emerging mutations right so these
emerging mutations down below
characterize these different sub strains
of this novel coronavirus
you have some options here on the site
that I encourage everybody to try and
play with you can see here the different
datasets you can change your settings
and kind of see how it relates to some
of the other things as well so
fascinating way to connect all the data
together but the key to this connection
is really the analysis so we don't have
that much time left but what I want to
leave you with is to start asking that
question another place that we should go
to is a place where all of these
sequences could be easily found and you
can start analyzing them so this is the
link that we want to go to it's the
viral the NCBI virus you can click right
here search by virus and type in
coronavirus and we want to look at the
beta coronavirus together so this is a
link to get to the beta coronavirus I'm
going to paste the link right here and
let's take a look at some of this
information that anyone including
yourself and me we can find and we can
start looking at so here you can see the
accession numbers you can see the length
of their genome the geolocation you can
see host isolation where they were
isolated from and the collection date so
oops
okay there's a lot of data here right
obviously you need to filter this data
so for those of you that have a little
bit more time I'm going to walk you
through on how to select a meaningful
data set from here and show you how to
do a very quick simple analysis to
understand this relationship that we saw
from from a phylogenetic standpoint
right so the first thing that we'll look
at is phylogeny of these different
sequences okay so what kind of
information do we have we can download
this information and start filtering it
in different ways we have the strain
count country host the GenBank accession
and we can start grouping those by a
specific variation that we can that we
can identify so let's think of how to do
this quickly to do this I'm going to
demonstrate it to you here if you're
going to be joining future sessions
we're actually happy a green account for
you to try and play around with some of
this stuff what we will do is we will go
to our platform and we'll try to build a
phylogenetic tree with one of the
examples that we prepared for this
session so the platform link is server
dot T - bio the benefit of this platform
is that it allows us to do fairly
complex analyses on a variety of
different data types many of these same
algorithms are implemented in different
ways on different solutions so I'm not
saying that this is the only way to do
it in fact you can build a phylogenetic
tree right there on the virus NCBI
resource but here the benefit is that
this is going to be a resource linked to
your students projects and you can
monitor all of their activities if you
are a teacher in a school you can
monitor all of their activities and link
them to specific projects
and courses that we have available
online so in this whole section you can
see that we have next-generation
sequencing data we have mass spec data
structural biology data and then data
integration and modeling and so we're
not gonna be processing right now the
raw reads from sequencing what we will
do is take prepared genomes and I'll
just show you a quick demo to leave you
with some idea of how you would go about
it yourself so we will go here and
analysis of virus quasi species where we
will do multiple sequence alignment and
phylogenetic analysis so we will start
by taking a list of sequences from that
virus database that we just looked at
remember the paper that we're following
took three different bat genomes one
penguin genome and a couple of human
genomes then we will go to multiple
sequence alignment at the nucleotide
level after that we will convert that
alignment into amino acid alignment so
we want to understand which nucleotide
changes caused the change in the amine
and we will annotate those by their
codon position in the different genes
coding for different proteins then we
have here implemented number of
different phylogeny methods but what we
will use is beasts and ape and we'll
talk about those methods more later but
we'll build a phylogenetic tree and then
we'll analyze those phylogenetic trees
to select the best one that we think is
representative of what really happened
okay so now we can take a look at what
some of those outputs look like here you
can see a number of different outputs
some of them are faster format so you
saw the multiple sequence alignment
wasn't fasted before that so some of
them are going to be tables that you can
open in Excel for example and look at
frequency of mutations and things like
that some of them are PDFs that show us
the different outputs in a phylogenetic
tree visualization so let's take a look
at this PDF
we'll just download it like this and
let's see the result
so here tell me how many distinct groups
do you see in this visualization
for
you
anyway no for great so we see fork
plates for clades and the question is
what are they right so how do we know
what they are how could I find out what
for example is common between these
genomes or common between these genomes
great thank you everyone for your
answers how do you think I could
actually have a sense of what these
groups are okay analyte we already an oh
yeah accession idea exactly so these
codes are accession IDs so let's try and
find them real quick to understand what
this means so where is our virus and CI
virus okay so this is the accession ID
alright let's just search for it like
this and we'll find it on NCBI
it's going to be I'm going to look for
this
okay so what this is is the human
coronaviruses OSI 43 from USA from the
1990s complete genome right
you
okay so let's first look at the
accession number right then we'll look
at why so all the other answers that you
guys had is why right so we can analyze
our sequences to understand how are they
different we can annotate the different
proteins to understand the functional
differences etc right but at the first
level we just want understand okay did
this produce some kind of a meaningful
result okay so we notice that the first
one is the beta coronaviruses from the
1990s let's take a look at this one
the lack of space
now that's okay
Elsie
okay so here again we will have the
nucleotide sorry
okay this record was removed but you can
see that this was novel coronavirus -
from Japan and so so so forth right and
we can see our group frame stands for
the reference you know that we used and
as you remember this is the reference
genome that we originally used for this
novel coronavirus so to simplify the
story let me point you to another
resource that we developed that can help
link all of this information together so
here you can see how the frequency of
mutations right so here we see we can
play around with some of the tools that
we have here just send this to everyone
okay we see here the protein sequence
and the different proteins
that you can look at there
there's 3d structure you can learn about
what each protein does and you can of
course look at what kinds of changes
occur in that protein sequence based on
the nucleotide sequence that we see
right here so for example here we see
the reference genome the reference
genome is the normal coronavirus and
here we have different strains you can
click on each one and see where it's
from we have here different beta
coronaviruses so you can see that Cova
19 so beta coronaviruses and worse and
there's a couple of different examples
right here that you can switch between
so for example how do all the code 19
strains compare or how do different
types of coronaviruses compare and you
can see that the frequency of mutation
is going to be marked by either gray
which is zero or red which is a lot and
that will vary between different bins
and but by looking at this overview you
can really see how you can start seeing
the significance of change in more
general terms between and we have
between what we have in general right
the distance between these different
viral genomes so this is where I think
we we can go further in our future
sessions and the next session that we
plan to organize is going to be related
to to the different proteins that we
plan to analyze to better understand how
the virus enters the cell how it
replicates and what would be the
different outputs from these different
algorithms that help us analyze
so I just wanted to get this
presentation to a stopping point before
we open this for questions now I see
that a lot of you have questions so let
me pause here and start answering some
of those so first of all our main raise
was asking if you want genome then can
you download it from ensembl and what do
you want to do
finding mutations between different
constrains of Corona miners okay so a
great question
what we plan to do right is follow a
paper that we started talking about
which was which was analysis of amino
acid mutations in specific protein
sequences that can help us understand
how different sources potential sources
and potential hosts where the virus came
from would be would give us an insight
into the process of transfer of this
virus from different hosts to the human
sorry okay
the second question can I share the
presentation yes I will be happy to
share the presentation we will email it
to participants that are interested in
this with a survey and to better
understand how all this might have been
relevant or useful for what you do
because we do want to understand how to
further advance these types of resources
and add I've done to the need out there
we also we also want to understand how
next sessions could be useful for you
and your students so as I mentioned in
our next session let me give you a
little overview of what we will cover in
our next session we will talk about the
biology of corona viruses where the
replication is facilitated by different
proteins and by analyzing the different
proteins we
will better understand how the changes
between different viruses result in for
example higher infection rate invasion
from immune response and others and
we've prepared a number of different
resources that we didn't have a chance
to talk about today that really go
deeper into the structure of different
proteins the different functional
domains of proteins and we'll in detail
kind of understand how does this virus
actually work what does it do with these
different proteins and how these
mutations can help us answer some of the
questions that we might have about the
viral process okay some of the questions
that are posed here why don't we use
blast and yes for sure you can use blast
blast as local alignment so it's not
going to work well for all the full
genome so for full genome use multiple
sequence alignment what is tax ID e tax
ID as we looked at there's a taxonomy of
these viruses so when you use that to
associate them with different sub
strains genera species etc if a virus
still shows mutation I would want to
design a vaccine yes that's exactly
where we're going with all of this we'll
talk about knowing the position of the
mutation will give us a lot of insights
into vaccine design but we first have to
go through the steps to get there by
this analysis can we identify some
hotspots that are more prone to mutation
studying different strains from these
outbreaks exactly that's a very good
point in fact we will talk about the
receptor binding domain that we'll show
friends is between different hosts and
different strains of the virus and an
important part in vaccine device design
can we develop an inhibitor that's a
very good question and a good question
is to ask yourself inhibitor of what
right so an inhibitor means that it
slows something down what do we want to
slow down we can slow down virus entry
into the cell we can slow down
replication if we have replication
it is not done by the same protein right
so there's
another protein that is responsible for
different aspects of this viral
replication so we need to look at the
different protein ask ourselves what
kind of data set can answer a question
that you might have okay what cell types
Express h2 epithelial cells just off the
top of my head
you can definitely look into it it's a
good question yes so we will talk about
next time how this protein the surface
spy glycoprotein connects to the ACE
turn we'll talk about that receptor in
detail
all right great so good questions
everyone thank you again for joining let
me just finish with one more one more
slide we do encourage all of you to
think about these questions that we
started looking into today we showed you
today some of the tools that you can use
we for participating in science courses
next school year I would recommend
connecting with science coach so science
coach is a program you can see the chat
message from Jill there is a there's a
specific website called science coach
that orgy where you can learn about
science coach if you're interested in
bioinformatics then you can go to
science coach t - bio info and we have a
lot of different questions answered
Thank You beeps on our blog post where a
lot of these questions are addressed in
detail yes the
bunju a very good idea I think this is
something that a lot of people are
looking into all right
and we will definitely send you more
information and the recording in this
webinar so this is what we have in mind
for our next couple of sessions if you
would bring your students your kids or
join yourselves to learn more about
science coach and bioinformatics for
code with 19 we would be happy to have
you again thank you again and have a
great day everyone
you
[Music]
yes sorry last question is it paid or is
it free so science coach has a program
for teacher training we will probably
send you more details by email about
teacher training available from science
coverage thank you